her I love that idea
um what's your observation about the
women that you grew up around on average
versus the women in England like what's
your impression on the main difference
how do women
um
I would say the women in England are a
bit more like they're better dressed and
they're more proper
um when it comes to relationships I
think England is so similar to the US
like it's honestly the same um the
average age of first bear like they get
married a little later up there it's
like 31 where it's like 27 28 here
that's true but it's it's
it's the same from my perspective the
women are way less promiscuous in
England than Australia
and I know that's a massive
generalization but girls in America are
hosts on average there's like a lot of
sluttery going on yeah and I remember
one time me and my girl went to
Australia for like two weeks and we had
it in our head the whole time because we
were like doing these Music Festival
appearances or whatever we had it in our
head the whole time that we were going
to meet this hot Australian chick and
hook up with her and literally every hot
Australian chick we met had a boyfriend
by her side which shout out to them
because they all seemed very happy and
secure but it just it just seemed like
in Australia it was like so much more
normal to just be in relationships
you had the same experience in England
yeah I would say on average oh really
I've had a lot of single people on my
show so
you're you're drawing them in that's
true like that's what I'd say most
people I've met are through my show
really there's less of a stigma in
America about having a high body count
than there is in England whereas in
England I would say it's probably a
bigger deal the girls are quieter about
it I think than in America so I would
agree with you like because there will
be girls again like I meet people
through the show like they'll come on
the show and they'll talk and like say
one thing but then like oh my God this
one girl
I'm thinking of a story off the top of
my head this girl comes on the show and
she when she was beautiful this is like
probably one of the prettiest girls in
the bottom of my show the whole show I'm
done with the bad guys like I'm I'm
healing healing whatever and
um and she was just talking all this
talk how she doesn't like do any like
blah blah blah after the show my my um
recruiter brought one of his friends to
like watch and he literally took her
home after the show and I'm just like
oh so I feel like girls in England like
kind of like taught like we're like the
girls in America are a little more open
but let's be real it's very easy for a
person to be promiscuous without
informing the world about it like you
could you could very easily have had sex
with 60 people and just not tell me and
not really let on like it would be the
easiest [ __ ] thing in the world for
you to let on for you to like keep that
ruse going wouldn't it me too like you
if I told you I had sex with five girls
I mean I don't know I felt like maybe
the tattoos kind of like give it away
that it just looks like I have more life
experience also why are you 39 also why
are you a porn star but I mean it's just
like a very easy thing to lie about I
feel like
um you could do your sneaky [ __ ] and
that's and everyone knows that it's why
we don't like really believe girls
numbers I just feel like the truth comes
I'm just a big believer and the truth
comes out eventually if you facts with
60 people six like that's so many people
someone's gonna know someone no but the
world is huge I'm a big believer in
being a good liar like just keeping your
[ __ ] close to your chest and like I like
some of the dudes that I've had so much
respect for in my life were dudes who
everyone thought that they were like not
a [ __ ] and then once I really got to
know them I started to realize that they
were [ __ ] all the time and they just
actually did an Immaculate job of not
letting their friends know they weren't
bringing girls to the bar to meet their
homies or whatever because I was a total
opposite I was like literally going to
the bar with a different chick every
night of the week I don't give a [ __ ]
all my friends can meet her I'm never
gonna see her again it is what it is you
know like it was just
I was terrible at keeping my [ __ ] on the
deal yeah but again then you got to know
him and you find out like that's what
I'm saying eventually like someone's
gonna talk like I'm not saying like sure
you can do it where like people that are
two or three like that don't know you
that well like will never know but I
just think eventually Something's Gonna
Come up like so you're a real smooth
criminal maybe but I'm just a big
believer and the truth comes out
eventually you'll even see celebrities
like it'll be like 20 years later and
someone will say something like oh I
hooked up with her when she was younger
right so I just I feel like the truth
comes out eventually it can but if
you're really fear really with your [ __ ]
or but that's why you get prostitutes
because then they're not going to tell
nobody right
yeah I was in theory yeah and then if
you tell them if you actually tell
nobody but I feel like you always tell
someone like people usually tell someone
what would you say to like do you think
that young men should go to prostitutes
um if they just want to get it out of
their system
um oh gosh this is a good question I
have mixed feelings because I don't I
don't really like the idea of that but I
also feel like it's kind of the way the
world's always been so it's like that's
the world's oldest profession like
someone's kind of got to do it right you
know could it couldn't be me but I
wouldn't want someone I love to do it
but
um and it's like what other solution do
you have for the one out of three month
under 30 that our virgins are haven't
had sex in the past year I just
sometimes feel like if you're a young
dude and you have the opportunity to do
it which I don't think I did when I was
a kid I would have had no idea where the
fourth of prostitute in New Hampshire
when I was growing up but I'm just
saying like if if the idea of sex is so
nerve-wracking and oppressive to you in
your head
you could just you know pay somebody for
their time and actually this is what
like the sex worker Community would tell
you is like you know you should like
that's what they're kind of there for is
like for you to be able to pay somebody
for their time to have this experience
so that you can kind of demystify it I
don't think it's the worst idea but I
also feel like a guy making that a part
of their life on any sort of regular
basis is basically like suicide for your
chance of being successful at any point
in your life
yeah I agree with what you just said I
agree it's just like
humiliating it's like it might be cool
for like a one-off but you definitely
shouldn't make this part of your life
yeah yeah I mean
I would always say maybe go the other
routes first but I just have a hard time
I just have a hard time encouraging
prostitution I don't know I have a
friend who's like 21 and he just lost
his virginity so it's like a little late
but he's like a mega nerd and he's like
he makes good money and he's like doing
really well for himself but he's a
[ __ ] nerd so it like took him a
little later into life or whatever and
we had had that conversation where I was
like you know like before he lost to
Virginia I was like you know maybe you
should just get a hooker like maybe that
would be good for you to just like kind
of get it over with like that and then
he told me the story that I thought was
really fascinating right so he's hanging
out with his girl and they blatantly
kind of have a Vibe where she she likes
him he likes her whatever and they're
they're sleeping in like a hotel room
together right but like it's because
they're both at this event and it's not
like oh we're gonna sleep in the same
bed and before they went to bed she said
to him she goes hey I just want to let
you know that um you know we can sleep
in the bed and stuff but I don't want to
have sex and he's just like oh that's
cool like that's totally cool and so he
just goes to bed in the bed like facing
away from her pulls the covers up and
just goes to sleep and then she wakes up
in the next morning and she's acting
kind of weird and eventually he says
like hey like did I do something like
what's wrong and she was like well I
didn't want you to like not do anything
to me and I told him I'm like yeah bro
I'm like she didn't want you to she
wanted you to try to [ __ ] her she just
wanted to like be able to call her own
shots there and if she didn't want to
[ __ ] she wanted to be able to say okay
like I don't want to do this I was like
she definitely wanted you to like kiss
her like try something for sure
and then he ended up losing virginity
sir so oh I guess did they date or
anything
oh okay
[Laughter]
I'm like don't get hung up on her you
know I guess she's dope for sure but I
was like you really you'd probably be so
much better off like just meeting more
girls rather than like focusing in on
this first experience you've had
I don't know did you agree with that or
do you think you should really chase
this one
no I mean girls are usually repulsed
like I said chase them I think we prefer
to Chase
yeah that's true but it must be weird
it's weird for him though because
the girl almost certainly like knows
that he's not exactly drowning in [ __ ]
does she I would assume oh I don't know
your friend I don't know what he comes
off as he's not coming off I was like
Mister big dicks as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible